zweieinhalb flugstunden von deutschland
entfernt hat ein diktator sein volk in
geiselhaft genommen
ihm ist egal wo seine kritiker leben
weil lukaschenko es macht in frage
stellt wird gefoltert getötet entführt
wenn sie sich das video ihres sohnes in
haft anschauen sehen die eltern von
roman protosevich vor allem eines spuren
physischer gewalt ich sehe das eher ins
gesicht geschlagen wurde
obwohl es überschminkt wurde ja es durch
make up abgedeckt aber man sieht es
trotzdem
das sieht doch so aus als ob ihm zähne
auf der linken seite fehlen
ich kenne meinen sohn
ich sehe das eher eine gebrochene nase
hat als regimekritischer journalist
gerät nicht nur romand process which in
lukaschenko visier
auch seine eltern müssen aus belarus
fliehen in ihrem polnischen exil
verfolgen sie wie ihrem sohn die
organisation von massenunruhen
vorgeworfen wird darauf stehen 15 jahre
haft im video sagt der 26 jährige
er werde mit den ermittlern kooperieren
wohl unter zwang
wie kann ein mensch etwas gestehen dass
er nicht getan hat und massenunruhen hat
es ja auch gar nicht gegeben man hat
nichts kaputt geschlagen kein getötet
und keine läden geplündert nichts
dergleichen
in belarus wissen die polizisten wie sie
an geständnisse kommen sagt zg
er ist einer der wenigen die sich noch
trauen uns in minsk ein interview zu
geben
auch er hat angst doch über seinen
freund zu reden ist ein wichtiger roman
sergej kennen sich aus ihrem
fußballverein
er hegt eine große abneigung gegen
ungerechtigkeit und lüge und eine große
liebe zu belarus das zusammen hat ihn
wohl dazu gebracht für nächte zu
arbeiten roman crazy [ __ ] ist
chefredakteur von netter als das
oppositionelle online medium im sommer
2000 20 millionen nutzer erreicht mit
videos von friedlichen protesten und von
brutaler staatsgewalt es sind die wochen
in denen bela russinnen landesweit für
freiheit gegen gefälschte wahlen und
gegen alexander lukaschenko auf die
straße gehen netta postet auch
informationen darüber wann und wo die
proteste stattfinden
im warschauer hauptquartier von nicht
erklärt uns der pan pot ilo
sie seien den schritt vom journalismus
zum aktivismus bewusst gedankt für die
hoffnung auf demokratie unsere
bürgerschaftliche verantwortung und
unsere gedanken an die zukunft des
landes und die zukunft unserer kinder
erlaubten uns nicht in passive am rand
zu leiten die menschen haben uns gebeten
ihre aktionen zu koordinieren als alle
anderen kanäle vom regime blockiert
wurden und natürlich übernehmen wir die
volle verantwortung dafür ist der party
los arbeitsplatz wird streng bewacht wie
roman protosevich steht er auf
lukaschenkos terror fahndungsliste
aufgeben kommt für den blogger nicht
infrage obwohl er den protesten in
belarus kaum noch eine chance gibt
jeder protest wird mit hilfe von waffen
kugel schlägen und morgen in
gefängnissen und verfolgungen brutal
unterdrückt die leute haben angst die
menschen werden selbst wegen weiß-rote
jalousien wegen eines weiß-roten
mundschutzes inhaftiert weiß rot weiß
die farben der bilder russischen
opposition
der gehört auch lena an nachdem sie von
polizisten in zivil am helllichten tag
in ein auto gezerrt wurde
ihr schläge angedroht wurden und sie
erst zehn tage später wieder frei kam
lebt die journalistin heute in will muss
seit romans festnahme fühlt sie sich
allerdings auch hier nicht mehr sicher
ich bin mir sicher dass bei seiner
entführung und andere operationen die
geheimdienste russlands zum einsatz
gekommen sind
der fsb der gu und andere spezialkräfte
ich bin mir sicher dass sie auch hier in
vilnius agieren
für eine direkte beteiligung russlands
an der erzwungenen notlandung samt
festnahme sieht der politologe ball wäre
cavalli witsch bisher keine belege aus
minsk wagt er eine andere analyse
diese situation ist für russland von
vorteil
je mehr konflikte velos mit dem westen
hat desto mehr hängt lukaschenko von
russland ab und umso höher aegerter ihm
sein
lukaschenko ist machthaber von putins
gnaden ohne die milliardenkredite ohne
die beistandsgarantie aus moskau hätte
er die proteste des letzten jahres
womöglich nicht überstanden im gegenzug
drängt putin auf eine einheitliche
währung ein gemeinsames steuersystem die
endgültige union zwischen russland und
belarus artiger notizblock hier
breitbeinige gelassenheit dort es ist
klar wer die oberhand hat in seiner
reaktion auf die eu-sanktionen
beschreibt lukaschenko sich heute einmal
mehr als opfer des westens sie sind von
der organisation von protesten zum
würgegriff übergegangen die suche nach
neuen schwachstellen läuft und all das
ist nicht nur gegen uns gerichtet wir
sind nur das trainings areal ein
testgelände für sie bevor sie weiter in
den osten marschieren zu den waffen der
autokraten in minsk und moskau gehört
der information
gerade läuft in ihren starts medien eine
kampagne roman protosevich soll in die
nähe ukrainischer nationalisten gerückt
werden roman war in der ukraine aber als
fotograf und es ist sehr traurig am
beispiel unseres sohnes zu sehen wie
normale menschen zu geiseln politische
schachzüge werden romans eltern fürchten
um das leben ihres sohnes
ich bin mir fast sicher dass sie ihm
etwas antun werden wie sie es jetzt in
unseren körpern ständig tun und dann
sagen sie es sei ein herzinfarkt oder
ein selbstmord oder sonstwas gewesen
denn auch das ist belarussische realität
heute wurde witold a schoruk beigesetzt
der demokratieaktivist starb in einer
strafkolonie offizielle todesursache
herzversagen
doch als sie den leichnam überstellt
bekamen war laut seiner familie wie toll
es kopf bandagiert lang lebe belarus
rufen sie an seinem grab